everyone saw the trailer right praise
jesus you're fake
you're phony that right there was unkind
and dismissive i'm just gonna like
set the whole thing on fire and live how
i felt when i was born
you're black just a reminder okay now
why would you say something like that
i mean if you're godlike because now you
want to go there
okay let's go there you're gonna go with
mary to grandfather
mary married her
step grandfather my grandfather
so would you like me to break that down
for you
i'm in salt lake city with the newest
housewives
i am so excited to see you all in person
the first episode blew my mind
and i had no idea that salt lake city
was
so glamorous surprise there is also
an elite social circle this is hollywood
honey fueled by beauty
wealth and perfection surprise you're
fabulous tell us more
so let's begin at the beginning you find
out
through people whatever that they're
going to make a housewives in salt lake
how do you get involved happened from
lisa yeah it started with me
i do so much with the sundance film
festival and i had a lot of good friends
that work in production
and i was introduced to a mutual friend
to the production company i was
literally getting a blowout when the
call came in and
i was like on one and we had the best
conversation
lasted over an hour and a half and
they're like we have to do something in
salt lake
and so i was like cool what are we gonna
do and it started
you know thus like real housewives of
salt lake
i hold myself to a high standard if you
don't want the saint sanders go away
how did like the cast come together you
know i think it was like a lot of friend
of a friend so i knew heather
so i connected heather with the team and
then meredith
and then through mutual friends we got
jen
yeah we can't live without jesus it's
because she's mormon 2.0 oh whatever
she's mormon [ __ ] you didn't switch
with jen i told her we're doing a show
about business
women no you did not yes she did yeah i
didn't we didn't know it was housewife
to be fair
okay we didn't even think it was really
um
we kind of did we knew it i mean that
was one
i really thought it was going to be like
a southern charm type like
okay thing i just said it's a show about
business women in utah
business women in utah and i was like
okay you got me right now i have to
represent the minority
yeah we need we need the political
community behind
us so yeah and they are behind it
obviously there were meetings and they
wanted to meet you and get to know your
personality
what was that process like it was so
simple my name is
heather gay lisa had told me about it so
when i got a call from a casting
director i wasn't even phased
i had heard about it from her so we
spoke for about 30 40 minutes he's like
can i do a skype
interview with you today and i'm like
yeah let me shower she wants to make it
like try to look fancy i sat down and
chair in my bedroom because i just
didn't really think
it would go anywhere i just thought you
know i was just like
you know being a team player and so we
did it that day and that was the last
casting thing i did really now were any
of you
housewife fans have you seen the show
did you understand what it was 100
percent housewife fan okay like
it's inception of oc okay and who's your
girl sonia morgan yeah oh do you think
you're alike
i just feel i feel for sonia like i
watched her whole thing and like
she went through a divorce and everyone
was like get over it and i
you know it's not the way the world
works it was hard for her
and so i just i went on that journey
with her and so i feel i love sonia have
you watched
so my assistant in new york crystal she
summarized everything she gave her the
cliff now no i was like crystal look
here's what i need
yeah while i'm on this flight so she
summarized every
every franchise yep here's who everybody
is gave me the quick summary
yeah it was so good in fact my colleen
asked me for a copy of it
is there one housewife that you think
you're like
like i don't know that you're like
anyone else i've ever met so it's
going to be hard i think if we picked a
few different housewives from different
franchises and then put them together
it would be the birth of jen shaw yes
hey
the real gin shaw is here
i do like how in the first episode i saw
that jen shaw
is like a it's a full name yeah don't
you think that's my name
jinsha jensha jen shah but yeah that's
like
hyphenated and you had watched yeah i
had watched i started with beverly hills
um love that and i'm from new york so i
obviously love new york
i actually like jersey too um i think
it's cool i mean growing up back east
you can't help but not love
i mean you see a little bit of everyone
you know on those shows
and i know you have like businesses and
things so are you like a bethany
are you uh um surprisingly when we
launched our tequila brand vida
in 2007 bethany hosted the whole thing
it was like nuts like bethany was
drinking veta for 10 days straight
so fun so energetic so amazing and she's
like i don't even know if this is gonna
get picked up it ended up getting picked
up and
you know bethany's done amazing things
but yeah so i think i like
love bethany i felt a little connection
there because she was with us from the
beginning
so yeah love her have you spoken to any
other housewives
i've been hanging out with bronwyn a lot
and carrie brittingham just like we've
connected and they were in utah
and they've been like really great
actually i love that kind of like
housewife shaman like guiding me through
the process
what would you say the drama points are
for the season i mean it's not
housewives without some drama
you said it smells like hospital in here
jen smells like hospital
no you said it smells like hospital you
just be quiet that hurt me
are you done i'm pretty sure miriam
cosby everyone saw the trailer right
yeah yeah i mean that's it praise jesus
praise jesus and who knew her like how
did she get in
so mary came from one of my friends
cameron who's amazing he's had a
diversity for utah for like all of
silicon slopes
and so he recommended mary because he
used to preach at her church
got it and so that's how we got married
cosby yeah
and mary is the pot stirrer no no
no no jerry's the pot stir no i would
not call jen the pot store either
marries the popstar in her own like
excellent way just because it's like
hello
earth to mary this is what you said
yesterday what's happening
like right you know yeah you're right
that's totally unfiltered
yeah she's definitely she's gonna pre
she can read the room we're gonna let
her preach
i went to lunch last week with heather i
didn't know you guys had known each
other
gone to school and knew each other for
20 years kind of
i don't really remember her from school
whitney says that the um biggest
pot store are you two oh
i mean you know what's funny is i don't
clean yeah
i don't sure how i got this ring i don't
stir pots
i think the kettle is calling all the
pots black
and i think she's the kettle and the pot
she's super flexible though yeah it's
very flexible
one of the biggest shockers in housewife
history
is that mary married
her step grandfather my grandfather
so would you like me to break that down
for you please you're gonna go with
mary to grandfather
so what that means is
the grandmother was married to the same
man that mary's
married to right now but it's not her
biological grandfather but that's the
grandfather she
grew in growing up is is it to keep like
the money
in the family like i think that's mary's
story to tell yeah that's like america
i would have one million reasons why
yeah yeah
i i think she's married yeah
i mean i mean let's hear mayor i want to
hear
mary's i don't know if i've heard mary's
flow version story like i'd love to hear
it from america okay
and i've heard a little bit of mary's
story and i i it's not that
big of a departure for me like i
understand the concept of
faith over love yeah i understand the
concept of arranged
marriages like it is not that far
removed from
my experience or my friend's experiences
or my ancestors experiences so
i get it i get it shocking but i think
there's a lot more depth there if like
mary gets to tell her story
sometimes the headline speaks you know
it doesn't give like
the essence of what's happening i mean
you're so good on the show because the
eyes
don't wave your finger and don't get
ghetto just how what heather said like
it wasn't
such a shocker to her when i first met
mary
my personal experience i really thought
i was going to connect with mary
she's a minority growing up in salt lake
i was like oh that's
this would be my girl we're going to
bond and
so i went into it thinking that she did
tell me we went and had dinner and she
said
look you probably heard i was like no i
haven't heard i had no idea
and she said well i'm married to
my grandfather because my grandmother
left
put it in the will that that's what she
wanted to have happen i literally
was like okay girl do your thing like it
it it that wasn't it wasn't like oh my
gosh it wasn't until you know mary and i
had
our own individual issues with each
other about
personal stuff that you know just pulls
that out of the hat
well yeah no that's like i mean if
you're godlike because now you want to
go
there okay let's go there yeah let's go
there you want to go there
okay hallelujah amen
pass the basket oh hallelujah
jen who who pays for the parties
when they're on the housewives you have
to pay for it we do
yeah no but jen's and i'll have like
sugar cookies and sprite because we have
different budget
mentalities no way yeah yeah we cover
all of these expenses
well it's stuff we would normally be
doing yeah that's like yeah so that's
like yeah these are our lives so it's
like stuff we'd normally be doing and
then the cameras just come along what's
the most you've ever spent on a party at
the chalet
probably 82 000.
[Applause]
i flew in dancers from tonga she's got
an exact number
because yeah because that's what it was
yeah she's a hell person too because
that's what it called and how many
parties would you say
on this sort of level do you plan a year
at least one every other month there's a
lot more during football season
because coach shaw is not yet like he
barbecue so he doesn't really know like
oh i was thinking about when you had the
football player
the football player football
team and then when shaw goes out of town
we have like a girl no then it's like
i'm hosting all everything because then
it's sleepover yeah
does he ask questions he doesn't need to
know what does he need to know i'm like
hey the girls are coming over and that
pretty much means
i mean it's a fifty thousand dollar
dinner party yeah that means
transformers
[Music]
i guess in my closed small mind of never
being here before i didn't realize
how glamorous how fashion forward how
fabulous the ladies of salt lake city
were so what do you think the
misconceptions about salt lake city are
oh my gosh the list can go on and on
i think first of all that you have to
have
a club license to go out to drink i
think people are shocked that we have
liquor here we have a lot of liquor here
that girls are going to dress totally
differently like
almost like pilgrimy or not very cute
that we don't have good food here we
have the most amazing food here we have
like everything you would want here what
do you think the biggest misconceptions
about salt lake that everybody's mormon
a quick lesson on how to be a good
mormon don't drink don't swear treat
your body like a temple
whenever i'm traveling and people find
out i'm from utah that's the first
question i get
are you mormon so i think that's the
biggest misconception
they just are living it i mean every
there's a trace of mormonism in almost
everyone that's like native to salt lake
it's very rare yeah that's the truth
there are devout mormons and there are
mormons that have fallen away and it's a
very big divide
i don't i think to me it's so different
than that i just feel like i'm lds
and i just do it my way i think people
confuse the culture with the religion
but literally like church is an option
you can choose to go to church or not
i think that there's so many more people
like me in the middle that like
choose to live it yeah and then but
their own way because i
i own tequila brands and i'm mormon so
that's kind of
not the norm and i can sense from you
and from the show that you're a little
bit more
still upset about the divide yeah i've
had a completely different experience
than lisa like there's just
like i feel like attendance is
compulsory
at church like you're like it's a very
behavior-based religion so
as much as i would love to just like
have one foot in the mormon door and you
know and live my life as i feel to live
it
yeah it just doesn't work for me there's
too many
issues that are absolutely incongruent
with how i believe and how i want to
live
and and so you had to walk away
completely i'm walking away
in the show this is a process seeing it
i'm lighting my entire life on fire
and it is hard it is so hard
to be a good mormon i don't know what's
wrong with me like i'm kind of
embarrassed by my
smallness but um i was assuming that
people that were
in salt lake city and part of the mormon
church
were not like getting filler no
everybody here wants to look good like
that's your
largest demographic yeah
getting married and mormon mom's
maintaining it i think people
take a lot of pride in how they look
yeah maybe a little more on the inside
we could work for
but like well this is good for you look
at that yeah
what is the most popular treatment we
lead with lips at beauty lab like lip
injections are our number one and then
botox
yeah but you know everything laser hair
removal cheek injections chin injections
botox anywhere in your armpits so you
don't sweat and your palms
you don't sweat like yeah you know in
your knees in your knees so your knees
don't sweat
you know you're amazing you can't even
sweat me in a gucci
so like we're botoxing anything that
sweats yeah and we're feeling anything
that's shriveling
yeah and we're doing whatever people
want you know like we're not dictating
what beauty is they get to choose for
themselves are these women telling the
husbands
does everybody everyone's in on it oh no
no i don't think no one's telling the
husbands
my husband goes with me well john is
evolved
amazing dan your forehead looks great
babe no wrinkles at all honey
can you
yeah you have a unique experience you
know i feel like
you know i'm lucky i got a good husband
and you know honestly like i feel for
heather
i feel so much for heather but like
everyone
has such a different experience and no
one can discount it i also think one
thing too heather gave up
time of her life to serve an lds mission
and when you give up
something like that deep and are so
committed you're gonna have a different
reaction
than me who like right just tell me
about me
just kidding i didn't choose to be
mormon i would never have chosen to be
mormon but i was born into it
and i wanted to like yeah you know do it
right i didn't have a choice either
it was like you were born no and there
was no question
it wasn't and for me it was a choice i
decided to do
everything yeah you ran far and faster
i'm going to marry a black man
i'm going to muslims totally i'm going
to send my kids to
catholic private school i mean hey if
there's some
if if we can throw some diversity at it
true and i'm kind of like listen it
didn't work out for me and there's no
way for me to make it work out so i'm
just going to like
set the whole thing on fire yeah and
live how i felt when i was born
good mormon gone bad yeah it's like a
rihanna song
well it's if she'd write the song i
would be in the video just in the
background you know just
you know what i mean just what does that
mean to you because i don't think you've
gone bad
you've gone bad you have yeah i've got
bad
if you've been on this show is the
mormon gone bad like
there's no question about it like yeah
i'm a good mormon i've gone bad and i
want to just probably just not be even
a bad mormon i just want to like be
heather gay and not anything
but that's a huge horribly painful
process that i'm working through
is it a relief in some ways that a whole
new side of the whole world is going to
get to know you it's a complete gift
like the fact that this came
in my life like i don't think it would
have happened any other way like it had
to be like
crack it wide open like blaze a trail
set it on fire
and just let the chips fall where they
may and i don't think i would have done
it otherwise
and you joked in your casting video that
you could barely talk because you had so
much botox in your chin
i just recently i had them put some
botox in my chin
i wish i could smile but i can't i just
yeah
it's it was a reality i didn't i mean i
did the interview i wasn't thinking it
would go anywhere so i didn't really
care
i would have to hold my chin sometimes
to enunciate
but now i'm more careful but it's to
keep from like the
yeah scrunchy chin yeah well how much
pressure barely
i have a scrunchy chin i think i like
botox it's called the orange peel chain
i don't know
do i have it how do you think the show
will be received once it premieres i
think it's going to be
amazing i think so many people are going
to relate to all of us in different ways
i think there's something for everyone
i think people will be surprised i think
i think i'm going to get tarred and
feathered
so i'm prepared for no i don't think so
i already said filming i was like i'm
super [ __ ] up
so like people are gonna oh can you say
that yeah
yeah it's my favorite word yeah i mean i
think you have to go into it knowing
that you got to go all in or not do it
yeah and i think you ladies went all in
i think we all went all in
no questions yeah no one has time this
is the interview before
your lives change in such a major way
and i wanted to ask you each
before the world gets to decide what
they think of you
what do you hope that the viewers take
away from you and your story you know
the thing that i
um like really want is for people to
feel like they can do
anything like i feel like everyone
should just be 100 themselves
and whatever you choose to do be
committed with it and do it that's the
whole reason when
we started even going down this road i
wanted to be on the show
is because i really hope people feel
like they're not afraid and they take a
chance like
no matter what it is in their life it
doesn't have to be with business
anything
just take the plunge go and then just go
all in and do it
jen what do you hope people take away
from you i think i hope i
my story is you know obviously different
from the other ladies yeah it was
growing up in utah as a minority
and being a female and in business it
was
really really hard it was really tough
for me um you know and just everything i
had to go through so
for me i hope that i can be you know an
example to
other women minority women where they
have somebody to look up to because when
i was growing up i wish
i did where i was like she's she looks
like me
i can do this you know no matter how
hard it gets because it does get
very difficult and there was so many
times when i wanted to quit but
just um i hope that you know i can
i can be a motivation to other women of
color
i don't want to represent anything but i
just want to like be open
and like let people know that like
you know you can be in pain and still do
good things i don't know like you can
still
you know have a life well i think it's
really brave and i think this will be
uh both traumatic and a big
learning lesson you know and now you're
gonna have like all kinds of millions of
friends from around the world watching
you
millions of men bring me all the men are
you ready
to like get back in the saddle i've
never really dated or
done anything in front of my kids i've
never drank or dated in front of my kids
or
done anything but this throughout the
course of the season like
i kind of come into my own and start
like start like cracking open like a new
life for myself
what kind of guy you're looking for any
guy that likes me that's
just no uh-uh bar too low
far too low i know but like i mean i
just
i don't know i just i don't even know
because i got married like young
virgin ready to just you know be a wife
for the rest of my life
these are all really lovely things about
each of you know what's your worst trait
i did learn that i talk a lot and
john is an amazing listener and
production pointed out
that john has much more amazing things
to say than me
and to let him speak more i've learned
like really
listen more to john okay and i've
learned a lot more from john john's
genius
come in and wait for the camera john's
amazing
john dresses john john no come into the
light
i'm lucky because i got two gorgeous
boys from him too that are just
as amazing okay jen what's your worst
thing what's your worst character flaw
that's my words i mean i mean okay how
much time do we have no
my worst character flaw like it's
i didn't know it was a flaw i didn't
acknowledge it as a flaw
but i've been told until i started
filming
but i think i don't know for me it's uh
i think i go like zero to a hundred
because i'm very passionate and so i
need to realize like
other people don't quite understand that
passion
and it yeah it works well with lisa but
like some people it doesn't and so
that's
something i needed to i expected people
to just know
i'm going to tell you to eff off and
then i love you it's fine and culture
true like i think
you know it's jen's culture yeah i just
you know i'm polynesian we do everything
big i'm very
passionate i'm loud and you know
me and my sister might get in like a
physical fist fight but then i'm like
let's go shopping let's go shopping
no but like i love just as hard and i
need that was
you know for me i needed to um
understand that and also
i mean dealing with the loss of my dad
made me act out in like ways that
i didn't i thought they were anything
that they
existed but then going through like the
therapy and everything realized like
okay this is maybe i'm not as perfect
she is amazing and i would say the
bigger the heart the bigger the emotion
and that's what you get with jen
heather yeah i think maybe using humor
at any time instead of standing up for
myself good one
so i'm just trying to like figure out
that you can still
you don't have to go along to get along
all the time you can just really like
put your foot down and have some
personal boundaries that's like
something i'm learning
i love this well i am i'm so excited
about this season i'm so
i feel like so blessed that i got to
come to utah and hang out with you i
feel more
hashtag utah blast
[Music]
you